today's show is sponsored by old
Schwarzenegger as one sided chess set
I'll be black this is the technical
difficulties were playing citation
needed I have an almost randomly
selected article from everybody's
favorite reliable source of knowledge
Wikipedia and these folks can't see it
every fact they get right is a point and
a ding as a special prize for particular
dancers which is and today we have an
article with multiple issues
it needs additional citations it may
need to be rewritten entirely but
nevertheless we are talking about the
flag of Mars
so this is a question about the people
who make galaxy chocolate yes yes it's a
5 on this a big malteaser in there so
that's multiflo oh right I meanwhile
across the river there is the flag of
Cadbury's yes so much Benita Pablo back
to glory just loading cannons again move
Maltesers just as grapeshot
this is the most delicious battle at all
still pretty good hoodie Coleman
honeycomb and chocolate in the eye at
velocity so goggles obviously is the
first consideration yeah Hershey's won't
join until 1941 that's more of a comment
on their chocolate Cadbury sending in
the the first mounted freddo's
no other sending hazards could you
imagine the Devastator a dough's went up
to 20 feet there's a shortage after the
battle right Masek caramel guts ready to
hold over the place
Oh
Omar's like multiple rocket loads it
world war ii a mars bar like that i was
gonna the swiss chocolate is sitting in
the middle curly wurly Schuster's
trenching lightest to remember the
Cadbury's caramel rabbit yes Florence
Nightingale I always think you choose
the Cheesecake for the troops Oh try
killed a steady large the answer shows
still shows you gooey Center the
greatest life I've ever heard don't make
himself go to his like you know what
horribly I was laughing over the thought
of like wooden-legged freddo's melting
you want onto me it's a leg from Assunta
i say tosses right in those little
rabbits links german isn't he's not
swiss I thought yes whistle neutrality
that yeah I told you about this when I
went to the lint factory hello in
Germany did you find the weapon stop
sadly it is even better than that
cuz you know you go to the Cadbury's
thing it's pretty much on the side of
the real factory yeah you just one room
over well Lin I've got this little one
that's sort of on an island in one of
the rivers I forget which city it is I
do apologize and actually going through
they've got the fake little factory bit
and then there's this big display board
about mister lint okay
so he's headed down today mr. loom
started this company and blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah endured it out there
then the war start sadly mr. lint was
tragically killed in 1918 oh she went to
war you know I was bombing really
unaware no mr. Lin died when one of his
own fondant boilers
Ottoman delicious goo someone didn't say
that death by chocolate no I can hear
the damn you - there's a reason the
casket is closed but in death as in life
mr. lint was delicious alrighty now
maybe just the human equivalent of a
dime bar some the outside crunch inside
I almost feel sorry for a man who's been
dead nearly a long time ago in a galaxy
far far away we were talking about the
flag of Mars yes is it red only in part
is the red bit red yes are we going -
not sure why is the red bit Mars shape a
a circle known as tall it's it's very
much symbolic and is it a red horizon
and then sort of a black upper band or
something all close to that blue our two
stars no no I'll give you a point for
blue band as well got a red band a blue
band okay it's a it's it's a trickle
more like the French flag or the right
okay what sideways sideways red red blue
and green after Kim Stanley Robinson's
Mars trilogy red Mars green Mars and
blue Mars in that order representing
past and possible futures of Mars all
right green bean when we merge the
terraformer and blue when it has water
yes right so the green is a bit where we
saw turf it over and have a Country Park
or something like that
just-just that's where we're going to
send all the football because we don't
need it here on earth is a great great
idea you don't have to agree your world
of ours to I will be I will be on the
supporters books to notify idea of low
gravity football now more certain charm
to yes not to control did you ever play
sort of Brazilian football at school
while you're in the hall and off the
walls is perfectly valid yes it's great
it's a game is a game of football I can
actually get behind imagine that if we
could get one of these floaties you know
the big fan chambers where you pretend
you skydiving oh you can't control
anything in it your bladder gravity very
strongly Tom Scott pissing in the wind
[Laughter]
[Music]
so what's relative gravity on Mars it's
actually about a third of gravity not
0.37 really I'm gonna grasp sketchily
here with my poor knowledge of physics
but are we now talking about a pitcher
it's three times the size for the ball
to come down or do we just make the ball
three times heavier I have two players
to control themselves a game of subtlety
and panache yes the Martian game can
tell who actually bothered by football
here because you'd be able to jump
higher so theoretically that I think
we'd like a third gravity you could
expect someone to be able to jump over
someone else
yeah and that's an unreasonable
Quidditch and well I'm just I'm just
thinking actually we take it back to the
futsal thing and off the ceiling is
perfectly valid oh you would have a zero
you would have to have a roof that
solves it you have to be indoors and
there can I tell I was gonna be running
for miles
yeah damn behind a third a third gravity
potentially I mean how long could you so
do the halfway wall-running thing under
those species it's gonna dribble it
three feet up on the wall here past you
which you know I will know now I
wouldn't allow that I think that no no I
wouldn't be fine with it warning of the
wall what if you have we're not you're
running along the wall oh yeah like a
velodrome like a half yeah cuz then a
half past you'll be able to get enough
speed up to sort of do these curves
heard of the game is on these on Mars
yes I think that Mars city as they will
insert undoubtedly be no yo United there
may be two teams apart two teams I don't
know would inevitably have a home of
mass Darby I'm just eating the Mars
Darby would be on they wouldn't have a
home advantage don't forget that the
original premise is worth shipping every
one of the buggers up there oh no I was
thinking of starting no all over
nowhere dry it'll be like wind QPR at
astroturf pitch everyone said they're
unfair advantage I think it'd be the
same with Mars United I think they would
have an unfair advantage cuz they'd have
all the breathing apparatus tell you
what the away attendance is to be shot
when if you use a very lifeless crowd
here today
why do you few years down the line there
we have people grown up on Mars who are
presumably taller more adapts to gravity
like no Sam they look at it as an array
of semi of old dwarves wouldn't they hmm
she's wide we should just know this in
the book
what you saying is we should just fire a
Mars at Mars now yeah we really should
and leave the freddo's where they are
they suffered enough
eat nugget gee daddy imagine bastards
well I'm just thinking because there's
the the idea of rods from God
yes I'm rattled hyperaccelerated Mars
bar yeah Robson God do you know the
constant the idea that the only space
weapon you really need is a big titanium
rod just sitting on a satellite and then
when you're over the city you want New
Jersey just rot it put a titanium rod
like Rod Stewart and drop them on yes
yeah that's
that's my psychological warfare you
parachute him in still alive my name is
titanium rod yet I ironically
I'm the man who's in charge of the
titanium well arrives he has as much
kinetic energy as an atomic bomb yeah
would levels the city and all you need
to do is get nothing up there in the
first place
all you need that I do yeah someone will
drop one wrong there while they're up
there
Chicago I've I've got some bad news
there's actually thing that would
prevent both you know a legal thing that
prevents both the development of weapons
like that and it's the reason the flag
of Mars isn't official so we know what
it needs
who owns Mars bet they've sold off plot
to it like they have on the moon yeah
they absolutely have but again this is
this is the thing that prevents it they
don't know what the no the international
treaty are not being a dick about Mars I
leave you a point it's the Outer Space
Treaty it's very yeah the Outer Space
Treaty bands are weapons of mass
destruction in orbit or on the moon or
anywhere else it also means that all the
celestial bodies are open to mankind did
anyone tell China about that yeah well
presumably last until someone actually
lands that yeah well now it's ours yes
could you take a medical titanium rod
into space under that pretense that's
what happened with the super gobby yeah
the super gun when after the ban on NBC
for nuclear biological chemical yeah man
for that in Iraq he started building an
enormous ndon enormous conventional gun
with a bore of about a meter I think the
basic thought was if I can't have
biological chemical weapons are being
the biggest good oh yeah and they got a
piece in its project project Babylon oh
cool yeah the whole thing sort of fell
apart and whatever else but they've got
a section of the barrel in Duxford air
museum I think anyway in one hour all
length of 46 meters are year and that
was the baby one the first one oh look
around look at how's it made in
Sheffield ya know
it was it was a company called Forge
masters yeah don't forget if I remember
rightly that were it does say here the
metal tubes were purchased from firms in
the United Kingdom including Sheffield
Forge mass if you're gonna have a steel
company you call it so shutting the
water mr. masters well bet is that they
were told it was drainage pipe but they
were making with a bore on it in the
middle yeah we like we like we like to
run for City faster well there any
bullets left in the gun no sir
by the time we got there they'd been
rifled a big Babylon was meant to be a 1
meter bore supergun a space gun it would
shoot into old low orbit and then drop
back down yeah yeah the great phrase of
they said it was a sewage pipe but I'll
come in have a thumpin great muzzle on
the end there's some lovely commentary
here that neither of these devices could
be elevated or trained making them
useless for direct military purposes you
couldn't aim them you just shot at
something get something the distance and
whatever it hits on you go seek we could
move it and it's also in mobile which
means it has the same problem as
Germany's v3
you can bomb it it's there it's 500 feet
long
you're not gonna miss that you're not
gonna miss that you could see it from
Mars I'll just fill the bar with
chocolate and watch you explode right
we've filled it with fondant Labs next
time it goes off
it's mr. lint all over again there is
somewhere on earth where the Mars flag
is flying right now Kim Stanley
Robinson's backyard somewhere it's
officially flying by governmental decree
is it the same as another country's
flood no okay no somewhere it's I'm
gonna get bone over here so it's ends of
the NASA or the European Space Agency or
something it's one of their facilities
yes the flash line Mars Arctic research
station which is a great name yes does
any want to take guess where that is
is the fluctuation in the Arctic but
have been a couple of other fictional
Mars flags this is the one sort of
vaguely acceptable I don't want to take
guess what they might have been where
they might have been red background on
blue letters Mars oh you know what you
are so close it's okay no it's not
actually it's it's red lettering
where's yeah it's red on a white
background yeah and it's it's not quite
Mars but something very similar this is
from Heinlein stranger in a strange land
had not read that one I've read some
Heinlein but not that one
it was certainly the symbol for Mars
than the male symbol beside afraid of
that being you are essentially just
planting a science says mad what a
surprise from Heinlein yes I mean while
on Venus there's a flag that is just
there's a flag that's on fire briefly
before it's destroyed did you say that
there was a plan that someone came up
with to colonize the upper atmosphere of
Venus no so whatever tread boards no
because because the upper atmosphere is
about atmospheric pressure it's not it's
toxic air but if it's at atmospheric
pressure and you get a leak oh I will
walk up and I will see some Bolly
tacking the temperatures about habitable
the pressure is about habitable see if
you can keep a giant balloon up there
and the atmosphere is dense enough that
you could do that because our air is
lighter you could fear us to have a
bubble just sits just a bubble city sit
yeah just cool mind you that titanium
rod program is coming on a treat
actually going back to the earlier part
of this conversation could you get a
chocolate bar that could do that
I think re-entry might pose a problem
for a Mars but what if it were in a
wrapper
well I M&M so what so what so what
you're espousing is putting a mars bar
in like around that will burn up
perfectly through reentry leave here a
solid Mars bar which
then refreeze in the upper atmosphere
correct slowly defrost slightly and then
well it's not gonna be as damaging but I
like the way you're thinking
yeah who's like I'm just as the ultimate
middle finger is it we're going to well
I do believe we are gonna attack you
with nuclear weapons oh yeah we can take
you down with a mars bar gentlemen I
have an announcement I have a York a
strategically positioned over the major
centers yeah that is your weapon of
choice unless you can afford some of
that puffs dark chocolate but I don't
think the Swiss would sell it to ya
basically the the weapon of choice for
britain in these face chocolate arms
race howdy y'all has to be rocky yeah
we're not the Swiss will be winning out
the Toblerone on all that but you've got
to keep up with the arms race we'll just
pop a fruit and nut one with you saying
the fruit no I'm now channeling the
start of Flash Gordon oh yeah sultanas
hot hazelnuts most effective your
majesty fudge saw this going around
trying to catch it overdose me sir are
you destroying the earth on making a
desert but how many will die as arose
this attack
anyways I feel we've been building
towards that moment over the whole
episode Prince let's go home
congratulations you win
[Laughter]
you've won a holiday to a French resort
with Sulu from Star Trek in the director
of Transformers it's George Takei and
Michael Bay's week away in San Tropez
[Applause]
hey that's been Gary Brannan that's been
Chris Cole are the jobs gone we'll see
you next time
[Laughter]
that was our show if you liked it give
us a comment and let us know and there
are more than 30 audio episodes of our
reverse trivia podcast over at Tech
disco UK